テーラワーダで見ているのは
心はある速さで生滅変化していきます
そのものの生滅変化っていうのはスピードが決まってるんだから
それは誰にもどうすることもできない
で もののスピードだから生滅変化する
例えばこの我々の物体のスピードはありますけど
でも光っていうのは光子だから
光子には自分のスピードがあるんですね
それは減ることもないし
増えることもないんです
光の速度はこれより早くしようと思ったってもできないし
遅くしようと思ったってもできないんです
光は素粒子だから それで原子
原子見たら 原子核の周りにエネルギーの膜があるでしょう
その膜が回っているスピードはもう決まってて
それは遅くすることもできないし
早くすることもできないんです
いわゆる基本的な物質にも決まってるスピードあるんです
物質にも で その物質は固まって石になったら
石としてのスピードはまた別なんですけど
でも素粒子としてはスピードは自分持ってるスピードなんです
それ物質の世界 心にも心のスピードがあるんです
それは物質よりは早い
素粒子よりはすごく早い
光よりも早い ですから
自分が自分のスピードで消えて現れて
また消えて また現れて消えて現れてという循環で消えていっちゃうんです
そこでこの体に依存して心が消えて現れていて
最後にこの体には依存することは不可能になる
ですから 急に突然体から心消えるんじゃなくて
じわじわとゆっくりと消えるんです
そこら辺ですね みんなこのいろいろなことを考えるのは
今は体 心がしっかりと定着しているんです
そこでどんどん体が弱くなってくると
もう下半身はもう分からなくなっちゃうと
そうすると上半身で心が動いてるでしょう
そこであっちこっち弱くなって
手も感じなくなっちゃうわ
もう耳も聞こえなくなっちゃう
それでも心はもう体に柔らかく依存している
そうすると いろんな幻覚やら幻想がかなり現れやすい
そこで最終的に体のわずかな細胞にも依存しなくなる瞬間は死ぬ瞬間なんです
ですから 仏教からはいつ人が死んだかということは言いにくいんです
心臓が止まって死んだか
脳が止まって死んだかということは言いにくいんです
命はどんな瞬間で終わったかということだから
それは普通の人間の知識では
科学的な知識では言えないんだと
だから科学的にはこの適当に
じゃあ心臓停止にしよう
脳死にしようとか決めるだけで
どっちも最終的な決断判断ではないんです
ただ適当にほどほどに決めるだけ
で それ知ってるのは心が観察できる人だけなんですね
心で直接心にアタックすることできるのは
瞑想経験ある高いレベルの智慧ある人にだけなんです
そういう人には 心はもう自由に活動し始めたらそれ見える
それからこの心が活動すると
物質作るんです いつでもナーム・ルーパ一緒なんです
例えば体で心が動かなくなっちゃうでしょ
それでその巨大なエネルギーが体にほんのわずかに依存して動くと
あの巨大な部分には物質が出てきちゃうんです
新しい体が それは素粒子レベルなんですけど
それ見える人には見えます
ですから たまに人々言うでしょ
このなんか霊がもう体から出ていくのは見たんですよとかね
ああだこうだとか 霊とかなんとかいうのは
この心がこの大きなスケールで活動するし
そこら辺にそれなりの物質がまた生まれちゃう
ですから そういうちょっとした心のね
まあ変わり目 変わり変わってる心を持ってるならば
普段見える もうもう死んだと
そのエネルギーが抜ける瞬間といいますか
この体からエネルギー抜ける瞬間は
決してこの脳死の時でも心臓停止の時かということは決めることはできない
それは別にどうったことはないんですけど
そんなこと分からなくてもいいし
とにかく最後に大変なことにはなるんです
死ぬ時は 死ぬ時は痛いとかね
まあもう苦痛とかね まあそんな状態じゃないんです
この体に関わって痛いとか苦痛とか感じないんです
その人は大体死んだかも知らないぐらいです
もう体はとっくに忘れているんです
大体人が死ぬ場合は もう三ヶ月間ぐらいになってくるとすごい元気な人でも知ってるんです
なんとかの形でこの現象が出ちゃうんです
その人の寿命が終わってきて
でもすごい元気 もう計画は二十年ぐらいもある
でもなんとなく自分でパッパッとなんか変なことを感じるんですね
まあいいんじゃないかと
ですから その本人に現象が現れるんです
本人がそれは自分の死の現象かどうかわかるかわからないかっていうのはまた別として
ほとんど気が付かないんです
仏教のことを知っていて
人でも あ これ私はそろそろ死ぬかもしれませんけど
ものすごい元気だったらね
そう思わないかもしれませんし
で 現れることは現れます
そこでこの死ぬ時っていうのは
もう大変なドラマがとにかくもう時間をかけてゆっくり起こるんです
1週間とか 2週間とか 3ヶ月間とか半年間とかね
体がどこまでどこ どれぐらい
よれよれ状態でも 頑固としがみついて頑張るかというぐらいは
この死の状態が延び延びちゃうんです
ぽっくりと死ぬ人にとっては
そのその瞬間の出来事で
ゆっくりと まあもう死ぬ間際になって
1年かけて死ぬとかね
のんびり屋さんもいますからね
そういう人々にとっては
まあその苦しいドラマが長い時間続くんです
寝たきりになって ほとんど死んだ状態で
医学的にと看病する人々から見たら
ただ生きているだけで
植物だけで それでも死なない場合は
その本人の心は強烈に活動している
それで刻印された何かに引っかかって
ここで心が止まると止まるんだけど
そのまんまあの状態が続けていっちゃうんです
あの変な状態が そこでその人はそのまま
例えば人間か動物の世界に入ったとする
そこでその心が突然急に 1個の細胞に入っちゃうでしょ
それで意識が消えちゃうんです
細胞 1個の中で行動しなくちゃいけないんだから
大きいスケールで行動した心がまた見えない小さいスケールに閉じ込められるんですね
そういうわけで過去が忘れちゃうんです
それからこの細胞に頼って考えようとする
細胞 1個に対して何も考えることできない
それでどんどん細胞が増えてきて
その細胞から出てくる情報しか考えないんです
だから過去を忘れているんです
そこはもう心にとってはすごいショックみたいなものね
たまにこのあまりエネルギーありすぎ人々がこの一個の細胞にもう閉じ込めなくなっちゃうんですね
で そこでどんどん体が大きくなって
生まれてもあの小さな体で心は閉じ込めなくなっちゃう
それでもう過去は喋ったり思い出したりはする
で そういう特別なケース
その人々を見たっても
もう子供の割にいろんな大人の言葉言うわ
性格は随分大人の性格を持ってるとかね
で どう見たっても落ち着きがないやと見えます
まあ赤ちゃんらしくいる赤ちゃんは
もうこの体の中に心がもう完璧に閉じ込められている状態なんです
それすごいストレスなんですけど
ある赤ちゃんたちがね
ものすごいもう落ち着きがなくて
泣くわ泣くわもう混乱するわ
攻撃するわもう 何やっても嫌でものすごい状態あるでしょ
あれはもう前の影響なんですね
で 心はまだ落ち着いてない
それでやがてどんどんどんどんもう覚悟を決めて
この体の中で行動しなくちゃいけないとわかったところで落ち着いてきます
大体はどんな子供にしたっても
ある時期あるでしょうに
もう全然自分のことは納得しない
言うこともやりたくない
女の子で生まれたんだけど
認めたくない 自分が女だと
男の子で生まれたっても
自分が何者か知らない
大体男の子であろうが
まあまあ女の人々が育てるんだからね
で 自分の性別さえはっきりしないんですね
自分が何者かと そこで体が大きくなってきたら
まあしょうがないと ということで
もうなんとか落ち着くんです
そういうの明確にこの過去の心の流れの影響なんです
まあ意識がね はっきりしている子供だったらね
もう大体は言えることは言えるんです
ですから その言えない場合はね
その文化の中に概念がないと言えないんです
ですから このヨーロッパとか日本とかね
まあ言えないんです ヨーロッパ人が英語やらヨーロッパの言葉で言わなくちゃいけないんだから
その言葉の世界でそういう概念まるっきりない
日本の言葉にもほとんどない
ですから 自分がなんか変なことを感じるんだけど
この言葉足らずな子供たちの言葉がない
そういうわけで この過去生を思い出してしっかりと言う子供たちっていうのは
インドやらスリランカやらミャンマーやら
そういう文化ある国々では結構ケースが出てくるんです
それは決して稀なケースではなくて
変なケースではなくて
こちらの子供たちに言えないだけ
ですから 見たら子供たち見たらまあ大体わかるもんなんです
それはこの文化の問題です
そういう研究した先生もいて
その先生も同じ意見を言うんですね
なぜある特別な国だけで
こういうちゃんと研究して
科学的に それではっきりとこの子は過去世のことを言ってるんだと
この九十五パーセント以上情報を合わせてみて OK
になったら過去世だと決めて
なんで特別な国々だけで見えますかというと
その子供たちの文化ですよと
文化と まあそういう言葉の使い方で簡単に
とても簡単に使えるんだから
私はこっち来る前にあの家にいましたよということは
日本の子供にとっては思い浮かんでも言えないんです
でも ああいう風な国々だったらもうすぐ言えるんです
なぜなら そういう言葉はごく一般的にあるんだから
で 親にとってはすごいあのいい言葉じゃないんです
ですから とにかく抑えようとするんです
こんなこと言うなと でも言う子供はもう平気で言っちゃうんです
あまりにも平気で言っちゃうと
まあ調べてみる部分あります
本当にその子供が言ってる通りにそういう家がありますか？もう名前はそんな風にありますか？とかって
だから記録あるところだったら記録探したらもう何のことなく見つかったりして
まずいなケース本とか出しては出しているし
アメリカで出ているんですけど
カンザスか何とか  とにかく死ぬことっていうのは
そんなに大胆なことではなくて
ただの心の流れでそのまま流れていっちゃう
で 流れたところで自分の体も自分にも前の体がないとかね
で ショック受けたりもする
で 人間になる場合はもうそこで即然ショック受けて忘れますから問題ないんだけど
この人間でない次元に行っちゃったら
まあ自分がそのままだと思ってるでしょ
過去はそのまま覚えてるでしょうね
人間のこと覚えてるんだけど
見たら自分の体はもう人間じゃない
で 前の友達やら親戚にやら喋りたくて喋りたくてしょうがないんだけど
もう喋れなくなっちゃうし
もう聞かないんだから
私はこっちいますよと言ったって向こうには見えませんだから人間には
そういうのは世の中でごく一般的なみんな言ってることは言ったんですけど
で ここで言っているのは
このジャナカカンマっていうのは
この次の生 次の生まれを作るインプレッションに
刻印にジャナカカンマと言うんです
最後の時はいろんなことを思い浮かんじゃうし
そこで何かに引っかかった瞬間で死んだならば
その引っかかったことで次の生まれは決めます
どこかと決めることはできない
この世の中でいいことをしたんだからといって
確実に次の生は素晴らしいところへということはないんです
悪いことをしたんだからといって
その人は死んだらもう直行で地獄とかなんとかは
まあそんなに軽々く言えたものじゃないんです
体が弱くなって 心がもう暴走始めたら
何を思い浮かぶかということをわかったものじゃない
本人にもわかったものじゃないんです
ものすごい不確定なんです
不確定ではないのは心を育てた人
コントロールした人だけ
心をコントロールした人はコントロールするんですね
いわゆるコントロールできるのは瞑想の世界だけ
あるいは長い間 仏教のやら業の話やらね
いいことやらね そういうことをずっと聞いてもらった人々やら死ぬことやらね
そういうことはよくよく勉強して
欲のことじゃなくて そういう精神的なことを徹底的に勉強して理解している人々
もしかするとその時そういうふうに思考を働かせちゃえば
またいくらかはコントロールされますけど
あるいは悪い現象を見えちゃったら
おそらく私は死ぬかもしれませんと
おそらくではなくて もうそろそろ死ぬんだと
だから今悪い現象を見えてるっていうことは
私は悪いところにいることやと
あ それ良くないと思って
そこに執着してれば 私も結構いいこともしたのではないかと思っちゃえばいい現象が出てくる
中では暴走中だから 何でも思い出せるんだから
その瞬間に そういうわけで我々よく言うのは
人々に自分が死ぬということは常に念じなさいと
今でも死ぬかもしれません
ちょっと病気になったところで
どうやってこれ治すかっていうので
もしかするとこの病気でも死ぬ時は死ぬんですよと
風邪ひいたって ああ なんだ
風邪ですから早く治らなくちゃいけないと必死になって薬をバクバクと飲むんじゃなくて
もう風邪でもそっとしたことで死ぬかもしれませんというふうに
この死はいつでも自分の目の前にある
鼻の先にあるものだと思っておいてくださいというのは
その人々のためなんです
そういう人は病院に連れて行ったっても
まあもう帰ることないでしょうとか
何のことなく平気で思っちゃう
そこで幻覚出てくると
やっぱりまあ時間が来ましたと
そうすると悪い幻覚を抑えていい幻覚を作ることはいくらも簡単にできる
死ぬということを知っている人には
知らない人には無理 ですから
来世いいところに行きたければね
やっぱり死ということは瞑想しなくちゃどうしようもないんです
それで世の中はどうですかと
それだけは考えるなと
不幸な言葉だとよくも言うんです
それはもう欲の悪魔の教えなんですね
だから死を考えないことは不善なんです
死を念じることは善ですよと
病気になっている人に
まああんたはまあそんな調子ですからね
別にあんまり長くないということは
我々にとっては失礼な言い方なんですけど
本当は仏教から見ればすごい親切な言葉なんです
教えてあげるんだからね
あなたの命はね まあそんな長くはないでしょうとね
そう言ったら 全く教育ない人だったらね
宗教的な教育ないと怒るかもしれませんだけど
それでも言わなくちゃいけないんです
怒ったってなんで怒るんですかと
まだ 10年間  20年間生きているつもりですか？と
そんな調子でね 胃はもう完璧にガンで
それは肺までもう発展して
骨の中にも入ったってとかね
そういうことですよと
正直に考えたらどうですかと
また若さに戻ると思いますかと
まあ怒ったらそれでその人はまたさらに地獄に落ちますけど
ああ そうだなと認めたらもう来世は結構いい方向へ行っちゃうんです
ですから どうしても幸福な死に方のために
幸福な来世のためには
もう死ぬということはまあ徹底的に認めるということは必要なんです
この幽霊になるという餓鬼道に落ちるのは
ほとんどまあもう死なないと思っていた人々なんですね
死ぬということはもうないというふうなことで生きていて
そのまま一挙句先で死んじゃうでしょうね
それでもういいところは探しなくなっちゃうし
もう餓鬼道に落ちちゃうし
まあとにかく新しい命が始まる
それはジャナカ・カンマ
どんな業でもいいんです
で これ四つはとにかく終わります
ウパッタンダ・カンマっていうのは生まれてから
生まれてからその生命をサポートする業
そして支持と書いてますけどね
支持業 で 人間で言えば
まあ人間に生まれたらもうたまに幸福に出会うとか
そういう風に恵まれるとかね
そういうことよくありますからね
そういうのはもうサポートするんですね
業が その業 あの今世でやることもサポートします
例えば人があの不幸に生まれたとする
それでも一生懸命素晴らしく行動して生きていると
そこでその人の今世においての功績を見て
人々がその人を助けてあげて
褒めてあげて 大変楽にしてあげるということはあり得るでしょうね
それもサポートの業ですね
ですから 今世でもいいことをしちゃうと
生まれつき不幸かもしれませんだけど
いいことをし続けると
その業がその人の残りの人生をサポートして幸福にしてあげちゃうんです
そういう風にサポートの業があるんです
たまに過去世の業が飛んできてサポートする場合もあります
その時は人には何もわからない
なんかチャンスだとかね
偶然巡り合ったとかね
というふうな言葉で言うんですね
ラッキーでしたとかね
3番目はウパピーラだ
サポートするんじゃなくて妨害する
その生まれた生命の幸福やら不幸やら
それに妨害する まあそれどっちもでもいいんです
例えば人間に生まれたら幸福
不幸になる 生まれてから大変財産に恵まれている家で生まれたんだけど
まあ全部財産が消えちゃったとかね
自分が不幸にならなくちゃいけないとかね
財産があったんだけど
もう人生半分いたところでホームレスになってしまったとかね
で このあるホームレスの人をテレビでインタビューされてね
その人もうすごいいい仕事をしてたみたいですね
なんとかすごくいい仕事をして
会社で で なんかわけもわからないんだけど
仕事をやりたくなくなっちゃったと
全部嫌になってしまったと
そこで会社にも言う言わないで
もう突然仕事を辞めちゃったと
やめても何日かいると
まあどうせ奥さんに追い出されちゃうし
そこでも家もないし そこでそこら辺にホームレスになって
もうなってみたら それまた大変な状態なんですね
それで あの 今更考えると仕事を続けた方がいいと思ってるんだと
もう仕事には行けませんしね
それで死ぬまで その人はやっぱり不幸な人生をやらなくてはいけない
なんで何の問題もなく普通に仕事をしてうまくいっていたのに
いきなり嫌になったかと
それは心は変わっちゃうんですね
全部嫌に見えちゃう 投げ捨てたくなる
それでホームレスになってしまって不幸になる
そういうのはこの邪魔するカルマなウパピーラがカルマなんですね
で 逆に不幸の運命の人が幸福になることも同じなんですね
生まれつき人間がいろいろ障害を持って生まれたんだと
それで日本で生まれたんだと
日本よりヨーロッパの方が例えた方がいいかもしれませんだけど
で それでまあ別に経済的なね
そんなに問題あるわけでもないし
日本の政府もいろいろそういう人々を助けてあげるし
で 国にでもお金あるんだから
その人の必要な道具やら教育システムやらまあ仕事やらね
いろいろできてるでしょうに
で 指は動かなくたっても
ただもう口ででもコンピューターを動かすように機械いろいろ工夫してくれたりするし
足が動かないんだけど
指だけ動くんだったらそれなりの自動車椅子とかね
あったりするし それであまり苦労なしに全く健康な人々と同じような生き方はできませんだけど
それなりに人間らしく生きていられるでしょう
それもサポートの業なんですね
生まれた業が弱いんだけど
他の業が入ってきてサポートしてくれる
ああ これ それはサポート
間違った説明 今説明しているのは
邪魔する 妨害することなんです
妨害の場合は逆にね 健康的に生まれて後で障害者になる人々もいるでしょうし
健康的に生まれたんだけど
後でペースメーカーつけなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
若い時でも ある日私瞑想会に来た人なんですけど
ものすごくスポーツやらね
いろんなもう空手やら柔道やらすっごいもうバリバリやってた人で
仕事も頑張ってやってて
なんかもうすごい体力もあるんですね
突然何のわけもなく足が悪くなってしまって
強烈に痛くなってしまって
で 医者が見て この足はもう役に立たないんだ
そのまま放っておけばもうあなたの命までなくなりますから
取らなくちゃいけないということで足を切断しちゃったんです
で もうものすごいスポーツマンで
もう何のこともなかったんで
体にこれという病気はなかったんですけど
突然もう妨害する業が入っちゃったということなんですね
で 地獄やら畜生やら不幸なところに生まれる生命が早く死ぬのはどういうわけかというと
それはいいカルマが入っちゃって早く殺しちゃうんですね
で 次に四番目はウパガータ・カルマ
それは殺すという意味なんですね
殺害業 突然その人の寿命は殺してしまう
で 人間に生まれたら まあ一応六十歳
八十歳ぐらいまでは生きていられるんですけど
もう二十歳で突然なんとかあって死んでしまっちゃうとかね
なんとかもうなんとかわけで早く命を亡くなっちゃうとかね
あるいはもう何のことなく
もう誰かが病院に行ったところで
あの輸血したところで
ビーラさえ行っちゃって早く死んだりするでしょう
その人はこの世で別に何の悪いこともしていないんです
病気治すために病院に行っただけで
それで輸血したところでもビーラさえてそれでも終わりということにもあるし
そういうなんとかした手違いでその人が早く死んでしまう
別に病院がわざわざ人に病気させてやろうという人は全くないでしょうに
それでもする人がいるし
それにカルマ あの自分の生まれた時決めたカルマのエネルギーを途中で切るということは
殺害業なんですね 全部この生まれたカルマに関わるあるんです
人は生まれさせる業をサポートするか
それに邪魔するか それ壊すかと
そういうことで業がこの複雑で行動するんです
一項の業で生きてるわけじゃないんです
生まれたのは一項の業の結果で生まれる
それからいろんな業が入ってきてサポートする
また違う業が入ってきて邪魔をする
それで我々の生き方なんです
ですから 一人の人の人生の中でもう幸福もあって不幸もあるでしょうに
本当に自分がもう生まれてこなかった方が良かったのではないかと悩む時もあったりして
ああ 生まれてきて良かったということも時もあるし
その時その時いろいろものがあるんです
いろんな波があるんです
だから幸福な波があると
もうサポートの業が来てサポートしてくれる
不幸な波に入ってくると邪魔するから業が出てきて不幸になる
それから業のもう一つ特色があるんです
似たものを集まるという法則のように
幸福になるとどんどん幸福になってしまうんです
一旦不幸に回っちゃったら
もうそれが次から次へと不幸だと
それは業は似たものは繋がっちゃうんですね
[背景音楽]例えばわかりやすい例を作ってあげます
あるヤクザがいて まあ私たちのお金もう脅して取ったとする
そこでそのヤクザがもうそこでなんとかこの自分入ってる組合で喧嘩になったり怪我したりして
もう役に立たないと あるいは法律的にそれが解散されちゃって
自分がもうもう何のことできない状態になったと
そういうその人にとっては不幸でしょうに
いわゆるすごい元気で人を脅してでもお金取って頑張ってたんですね
運が良かったんです そこであるどんどんその自分の運が不幸な方向に入ってしまって
もう自分で頑張って仕事をしなきゃいけないいけない状態になったと
それでもいい仕事できませんだから労働とかなんとかしなくちゃいけないし
そこでこのお金取られた側が普通の人間だから
その人の立場はもう今そういうんですね
そこで突然その人に出会う
出会ったところで この野郎
私のお金こうやって取ったんではないか
もうただでは済みませんだからとにかく返せとか
またその人をいじる可能性あるでしょ
で そのヤクザさんの立場から見れば
どんどん不幸になっただけではなくて
もうとんでもない さらに不幸になったということなんですね
あるいは自分がやっと入った仕事を入った会社のもう社長に顔を合わせたところで
その人がお金を奪ったことがあったっていうこと
社長見たら自分を脅してお金取った人ではないかと
仕事をしているのはと
それからさらに不幸になるでしょうに
ですから 一つ不幸になっちゃったら
この似てるものはもう遠慮なくついてくるんです
幸福になるとまた同じことで
突然なりきりになっちゃって
金持ちになっちゃったら
もうやっぱり自分が高級レストランで食べたりするし
そこで人と喋ってみたら
その人も結構お金持ちの権力握ってる人々になっちゃうでしょうね
それでその人と仲良くなったら
さらにその人の人生がいい方向へ行ってしまっちゃうんです
そういう風にこの あの
殺害業と指示業 あ 殺害じゃなくて
あの 指示業と妨害業っていうのはその順番で流れてくるんです
そういうわけで 人生にはいつでも波があるんです
じゃあそこで終わります
すいません 今日 今日も話進めなかったんですけど
[背景音]